[Music]
[Music]
I'm Petty and you're canceled
what why don't ask me ask the person who
just took the last muffin cuz she cut in
front of you what was I supposed to do
she's in a and what Oh wheelchair so she
can just cut in front of people
beloved my darling I don't see the
correlation this does not an excuse make
okay okay I don't think I have the Petit
Jean my dear everyone has the power to
be petty you must look within yourself
if the Pettibone you can't find just
listen to this rhyme of mine look deep
inside yourself and the power you might
find use it with caution and care then
pettiness you won't fear tell people
they can catch these hands even if in
wheelchairs in the event someone has
done you wrong just listen to the song
and let your petty claws come out and
rip about you can let these mother know
you're not the one so get it right or
swear a bitching we can fight let's go
favorite shady tweets sin shaded twist
yourself leave a text on read laugh at
the person who fell go on my child you
try it I don't think I can it seems mean
you can go on sometimes you need the
power of peggy be brave
[Music]
I try to take home
everybody knows but it's hard when
people tells me son
I'll try some
be ready still
Hedi of
passive just to see what it
excuse me miss can you move I was here
first
no [ __ ] work stone doing the thing get
poppin what's up with you guys yeah
we're just talking about what happened
with integration last night last night
yes that's it yeah
why is my question when it comes to
these days yeah why exactly I mean doc
has now powerless against the GOP it's
absurd
yeah and ABCs what she's talking about
the basic fundamentals program for
public school teachers and you are so
right
they're having their funding slashed by
this current administration yeah and
teachers are the real heroes like why
cut their capes
yes Quinta what are your thoughts on
Dana's current comments to black lives
matter activist Mike last-minute um a
wrong mm-hmm and B just been yeah racist
yes right hate it's crazy well ladies
and gentlemen this has been riveting
your girl has a meeting so I have to go
but as long as we keep having these
conversations the world keeps spinning
you're so right when done
she gets a [ __ ] don't be me progress
yeah we are the change let's tweet about
this it's a one coffee that's going to
be $5 would you like to make a donation
today yeah sure
just pick one of the charities is Quinta
Brunson Quinta drinks won $5 cup of
coffee every morning $5 that's how much
a kid in the Philippines probably makes
in a day working on the shoes that she's
currently wearing it's true let's make
up for your sins we have three boxes in
front of you pick just one and you win
at clear conscience that is until you do
some other terrible first world thing
like showering for more than ten minutes
box number one and the boma research
help kids who are afflicted by the
disease by finding a cure you know when
I was younger my family and I thought I
might have Lukey to give a donation to
help a shelter care for those living on
the streets in Los Angeles help Ellie's
homeless today you know I actually
donated money to a homeless person
earlier today and Silverlake so I'm good
on that one oh you're good yeah what
clip
[Applause]
yeah okay box number three breast cancer
research and recovery help doctors find
a cure for breast cancer can I say
something is it about how you've already
given this charity in some way well then
oh good - today is the day and now is
the time pick one of the three boxes
make sure it's a good cause just
remember that you're not helping to
others all right okay okay I'm gonna
help the homeless right because uh
homeless just kills more people than
cancer no no no I'm not saying that it's
not about that okay I'm in that case I
will help breast cancer research in
recovery okay you have no problem
walking over the homeless in LA on the
way to your Saturday fancy-schmancy
shopping sprees okay no okay hey you
just told me to pick one that's what I'm
doing I'm just picking one box you know
what hmm I got $3 how about that yeah
gameshow daydream over this is over nd
$5 for the coffee oh okay so I made a
mistake I am actually put the money I
needed for the coffee in here
[Music]
I'm sorry I can't pay for this should go
[Music]
if the Pettibone you can't find just
listen to this rhyme of mine look deep
inside yourself and the power you might
find use it with caution and care then
pettiness you won't fear tell people
they can catch these hands even if in
wheelchair